guillaume zhukovsky bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
la matinale de rtl france alors nouvelle
nuit de violences urbaines on le disait
cette nuit à retour 3 quelle est la
situation qu'est-ce qui se passe
racontez nous la situation je pense
qu'il vous l'avez déjà cerlatez dans les
médias d'afrique qui s'est déroulé la
semaine dernière
comme je le rappelle aux as-tu à
l'ensemble des protagonistes justement
de cesser de les retourner au calme je
pense que c'est des faits isolés mais
dans aujourd'hui les faits se sont
déroulés maintenant il faut que
peut-être t chacun je ne veux aucun
parti mais que chacun avec cette
bataille d'égos cette surenchère et
trouver aujourd'hui des solutions
alternatives
parce que comment ça va se terminer
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être la question
d'aller poser après c'est que ce soit
les jeunes vont rentrer parce qu'il
pleut ou alors qu'ils ont une munition
de pétales ou alors que les forces de
l'ordre on voit déjà en ont ras le bol
et se mettre en arrêt ou en grève et
donc tu vas pas à ces défaites serrées
seront obligés de se retirer pour sais
pas ce qui est prévu parce que chaque
âge à dire donc alors que c'est les
mêmes problèmes qu'il ya deux trois ans
qui a dix ans et que depuis le début de
la politique de la ville dans les années
70 donc aujourd'hui je peux comprendre
des faits s'était isolé c'est ce qui se
passe là dire souvent inde et rodez
rodez rodez rodez d'incivilité la police
intervient parfois dans ce cadre là est
réaliste on travaille ensuite il ya eu
un accident
c'est un aléa qui peut arriver
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est pas non
plus le pin le quartier qui est en zone
de délinquance est pas une zone de non
droit nous c'est pas ça et je voudrais
vraiment calmé les cessations de chacun
la maire de tourcoing dorian pays qu
elle parle d'une intensification de la
lutte contre les trafics de stupéfiants
c'est comme ça qu'elle explique les
origines de ces violences du remède est
ce que c'est le cas dans ces quartiers
est ce que le trafic
stupéfiant est effectivement un
véritable le conflit au vous constatez
tous les jours chez oh c'est sur des
trafics de drogue
peut-être ok c'est une hypothèse c'est
possible et ce même si on va pas se
mentir de la drogue tue les points car
qui met justement j'ai plein d'arguments
contre sens dans les lieux où on vend de
la drogue s'y vend c'est très calme
justement on est on évite de les ramener
la police donc je pense que c'est des
dots problématique aujourd'hui sur les
gens beaucoup plus jeunes qui consomment
de la drogue
mais voilà après de dire qu'il ya du
trafic oui mais ça ça fait de nombreuses
années il n'y a pas eu d'intervention de
la police et 6 cas si jamais il y avait
des preuves
[Musique]
relater au je pense à tous les moyens
les forces de l'ordre
les enquêtes possible pour faire une
intervention on va dire coordonnées
ciblée sur les hauteurs en faisant des
perquisitions
accès par l'accident alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a retrouvés dans la moto alors
dites moi où quelques premiers avec kg
il ya bien un mode hôtel s'il y avait
dans les appartements aujourd'hui dont
on a peut-être qu'il y ait des choses
j'ai vu qu'on a trouvé des choses à
travers des projectiles des armes c'est
très bien c'est très bien draughan et
faut agir dans ce sens là mais derrière
voilà je pense que s'il y avait je
prends sur moi j'aurais dû procéder
comme ça si j'étais chef de la police ou
alors voilà que j'étais je le suis pas
assez des spéculations
je préfère moi apaisé et dire que je ne
prends aucun parti mais c'est de trouver
les solutions alternatives pour que
s'apaiser et que demain on travaille sur
des solutions alternatives sont les
vraies questions de fond
plus ils sont placés mais moi je vous
coupe la parole mais pour apaiser vous
avez des discussions avec ces jeunes
qu'est-ce qui vous disent justement
c'est toujours des problèmes auront pas
des zones de non droit et qui trouve que
c'est un peu grâce à celui-ci une zone
de non-droit on aurait dû agir depuis
longtemps et on aurait dû agir avec
coordination comme je les dis alors si
l'on savait c'est pas en venant ajouter
une moto pour arrêter le trafic des
drogues
je pense qu'on fait une enquête on
établit des preuves
on intervient à 6h à 8h du matin chez
les premiers qui hélas long de l'heure
alors on a un petit problème de liaison
allez y on vous écoute on vous a
retrouvé en été ou un petit problème de
lésions et peut-être voilà on était sur
les solutions vous qui êtes sûre sur le
terrain qu'est ce que vous pourriez
proposé comme solution mais à très court
terme notamment pour cesser ces
violences urbaines ces deux de ces
dernières heures pour stopper les
violences urbaines
je pense que je voulais tout à l'heure
c'est que aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est une bataille d'ego et
challans pas terminée parce que les
jeunes surenchérissent et chaque jour
désolé du der sar ou en direct les des
médias des politiques et les forces de
l'ordre de surenchérissent et donc comme
je vais dire une bataille d'une guerre
ça s'arrête quand les uns ou les autres
n'ont plus de munitions
nous on aura le bol et je mette en
arrivant donc aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
dire aux piles de provocation rentrée et
ce qu'ils sont il faut faire des rondes
à minima pas non plus venez nombreux de
ses respects mais il ya un couvre-feu
il ya des agents de police des
éducateurs
on contrôle justement en profitant de
cette pouf rocheux pour exciter les
protagonistes et si on les connaît pour
face justement une enquête et tous à des
perquisitions et que derrière il est des
preuves et pour les organiser pour
trouver des solutions alternatives
mais moi j'aime seulement je voulais
revenir parce que si on arrive à cette
interview
mais la zone de non-droit zone de
non-droit at-il d'éducation n'est pas je
vous pose la question l'éducation est un
droit
le logement est un droit le logement est
roi la santé l'emploi est un droit donc
de dire que c'est une zone de non droit
on est à la conséquence la sécurité
c'est quand il n'ya plus de ces droits
qui sont respectés en quelques secondes
et il nous reste quelques secondes
peut-être on a entendu parler aussi
beaucoup ces dernières heures de la
question de la mixité après la venue du
chef de l'état à montpellier et cette
femme voilier qui avait interpellé
manuel maquereau en me disant voilà il
n'y a pas assez de deux pierres
aujourd'hui dans certaines dans certains
quartiers en france est-ce que vous
aussi vous souvenez cette problématique
oui oui oui parce que c'est intéressant
de venir en quelques jours s'évacue
mêmes mots j'ai relaté des faits j'ai
demandé qu'on agisse sur certaines sur
certains sujets plein droit
et mais aussi l'éducation la santé
aujourd'hui les moyens
la crise sanitaire et économique
n'arrange pas les choses
mais il ya des choses qui peuvent être
faits avec les acteurs de terrain avec
des grandes concertations ont retourné à
une action plus ciblés plus locale et
émoi national et essayer voilà de
trouver des solutions alternatives avec
ceux qui le veulent c'est que le vrai qu
aujourd'hui il y en a un pour cent de
délinquance dans les quartiers
prioritaires ou 2% il ya un ou deux
tours sans d'éducateurs de policiers ou
de juge et aujourd'hui il ya un fort
sens de politique et c3 c3 % font pa ti
avec 97% de la population
somme je peux aller aujourd'hui je pense
que les citoyens en général les
habitants ont ras-le-bol et n'ont plus
envie de prendre parti est-ce qu'on est
d'accord la délinquance je pense que le
problème est beaucoup plus il est
beaucoup plus profond et que c'est ces
problèmes que je bourre si l'éducation
le logement et la santé et donc de dire
qu'une c'est une zone de non-droit jay
mc c'est très moche
j'habite moi j'ai parfois j'ai des
problèmes de logement de droit de maja
et de sécurité j'ai pas peur de me faire
égorger confection et à la campagne des
élections municipales l'année dernière
on a inventé la baisse de la délinquance
donc quand on fait de la politique il
faut savoir sur quel pied danser il ne
pas changer au gré de la situation
citoyenne démocratique et aussi de sa
cible
ou alors s'ils avouent ramener sur sa
mère merci à vous alors on arrive au
terme du temps qui nous a été imparti
merci beaucoup guillaume ducos qui je le
rappelle vous êtes membre du conseil
citoyen de tourcoing